[موسيقى]
ما وراء الافلام مع محمود النجار على
العربيه بودكاست من اكتشاف لطالب
الدكتوراه في جامعه ولايه ميشيغان لمذنب
بهدمر الكره الارضيه خلال 6 شهور والمشكله
الحقيقيه ان ما حدش هيصدق ان الارض هتدمر
خلاص طب ليه وايه اللي بيحصل ده اللي
بيحكي عنه فيلم don't lockup والنهارده
هاخدك في رحله للفكر الامريكي في التعامل
مع الكوارث الطبيعيه وازاي الاعلام بيداري
عليها فاهلا بيك في حلقه جديده عزيزي
المستمع عزيزي المشاهد انا محمود النجار
وانت بتسمع وراء الافلام المقدم من
العربيه بتبدا الحكايه مع
طالبه دكتوراه في جامعه ولايه بتكون
سهرانه بتشتغل في المعمل وبتشوف مذنب مش
معروف قبل كده بالنسبه للعلماء في البدايه
بتفرح اكيد جدا لانك اكتشاف عظيم وبتحتفل
هي واصحابها لكن بعد ما بتبدا تعمل دراسات
عليه بتكتشف ان المذنب هيصطدم بالارض خلال
ست
وللاسف هو عملاق كفايه وده هيسبب انقراض
للجنس البشري كيتو دكتورها المشرف راندا
المندي بيبداوا يتداركوا اللي بيحصل
وبيبعتوا لوكاله ناسا واللي بتوصل لنفس
النتيجه مذنب عملاق هيصطدم بالارض خلال ست
شهور وهيؤدي لانقراض البشريه وقتها كان
لازم يتحركوا بسرعه كيتو مندي معهم
الدكتور تيدي بيروحوا للبيت الابيض علشان
يبلغوا عن المصيبه دي لكن بيتفاجئوا
بمعاملتهم بلا مبالاه او اهتمام سواء من
الرئيسه او من ابنها وده بيضايقهم جدا لان
الموضوع مش صغير ومش دافئ وقتها بيتم
تشجيع على تسريب الخبر لوسائل الاعلام
وبالفعل بيعملوا ده لكنهم بيلاقوا ان
المضيف والمضيفه
بشكل كوميدي
وحولوا النقاش لهزار وسخريه وده سبب فقدان
كيت لاعصابها على الهواء مباشره
القاء بفشل ذريع بتبقى سخريه وتريند الناس
كلها بتشمت فيها ودكتور مندي بيبقى تريند
هو كمان بس بتعليقات ايجابيه على مظهرها
واسلوبه المتوازن على الهواء مش بس لقاء
فشل لكن محدش صدقهم وتعاملوا مع الموضوع
بسخريه تامه بيطور الموضوع اكتر لما
جوسلين
كل الاخبار اللي جيت قالتها على الهواء
مباشره وعايز اقول لك ان الشخصيه دي مش
بتفهم في الفلك اصلا كل ده هيتغير بسبب
السياسه لما رئيسه البيت الابيض او رئيسه
الولايات المتحده بتتعرض لفضيحه وتتحول
لحديث السوشيال ميديا والاعلام وعلشان
تصرف الانظار عن نفسها بتطلع في مؤتمر
وتقول ان فعلا في مذنب هيضرب الارض وانها
عملت مشروع كامل لضرب المذنب قبل اصطدامه
بالارض وبكده الناس عرفت ان في خطر
[موسيقى]
رئيسه البيت الابيض الناس انهم يتجاهلوا
المنظر في السماء وما يبصوش لفوق في مشهد
سريال جدا الارض بتدمر فعلا وبيانجو قله
قليله عباره عن الفين شخص هربو لكوكب
فضائي تاني قبل اصطدام المذنب بالارض بس
دي ما كانتش النهايه النهايه لو ما شفتش
الفيلم شوفوا دلوقتي علشان تعرف مصير
النيجو ولو شفته فانا واثق انك اتفاجئت
تماما من اللي حصل بعد ما كان عندك امل ان
الوضع يتصلح قبل نهايه الحلقه جزء من
بدايه الشخصيات في الفيلم واللي كان مميز
جدا وواضح زي مثلا شخصيه ودكتور مندي كانت
طالبه مجتهده ذكيه اكتشافها العظيم بيتحول
لكارثه متوتره دايما ما بتفكرش في الكلام
قبل ما تقوله فما حدش مهتم بيها ولا
برايها ولا حد بيتعامل مع رايها بجديه على
العكس دكتور مندي دكتور مندي شخص هادي جدا
بيفكر بشكل مناسب حتى في اصعب المواقف
هتشوفوا المتمالك اعصابه قادر يتعامل
بهدوء علشان كده في موقف مميز هشوفه وهو
بيقول لي
كان بيحاول دايما يكون الدعم
ازاي هي محبطه سواء بتحول اكتشافها لكارثه
او ان محدش مصدقهم خاصه بعد ما طلعت
انهارت على التلفزيون قدام كل الناس وناس
كلها شافتها مجنونه على نقيض الاخر علاقه
دكتور مندي بمراته واولاده كانت مختلفه
الشهره متغير اي حد حتى لو كان بعقلانيه
مع الناس بدا ياثر مع عيلته ويبعد عنه لكن
في النهايه رجع لهم وطلب منهم انهم
يسامحوه لانه عارف ان هم الاساس خاصه لو
كانت نهايه الكره الارضيه فالافضل انك
تقضيه مع الناس اللي انت بتحبهم وبيحبوك
تكوين الشخصيات والحوار في الفيلم ممتع
جدا
جميل جدا كل اللي عليك انك تشوف الفيلم
وتستمتع بنفسك بالاحداث في النهايه خليني
احكي لك عن ما وراء فيلم
هو عباره عن فيلم بلاك كوميدي هجائي سياسي
امريكي نزل سنه 2021 كتبوا وشارك في
انتاجه واخراجه ادم من قصه شارك في
كتابتها مع ديفيد قدم ادوار البطوله
لناردو
وتمثل
سنه 2019 ومن انتاج شركه ماكايز
تم الاشاده بفيلم لاداء الممثلين لكن
النقاد انقسموا الفريقين تم اختيار الفيلم
كاحد افضل عشر افلام لسنه 2021 من قبل
المجلس الوطني للمراجعه ومعهد الفيلم
الامريكي وبالمناسبه عايز اقول لك ان
الفيلم حصل على اربع ترشيحات لجوائز
العسكر وبما في ذلك افضل صوره واربعه
ترشيحات لجائزه
بما فيهم افضل فيلم وست ترشيحات لجائزه
اختيار النقاد بما في ذلك افضل فيلم
الفيلم في تفاصيل كتير مش كفايه يتحكي لك
عنها لكن المهم تشوفها بنفسك وتستمتع بكل
تفاصيله وتحكم بنفسك شوف الفيلم دلوقتي
واستنى لي الحلقه اللي جايه بفيلم جديد من
بودكاستماره الافلام المقدم من العربيه
[موسيقى]